next up pavel and i are going to
introduce you to some
creative ways that you can solve
problems in night city
av i have a job for you
a client of mine is making an arm steal
he needs
protection it could get hot
very hot the gun dealers are maelstrom
alas nothing ever transpires us
with them you better gear up for this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
put my weight on you and tell me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you willing
yeah i'm in
pavel thank you so much for joining me
now there was an
awful lot in that video right because
it's more than just guns
absolutely we have melee weapons we have
ranged weapons we have cyber where we
have
offensive cyberwear defensive cyber
armor
we could talk for hours and hours about
this stuff
i think just for today's episode we
should keep it simple and let's just
talk about
guns can you tell us the different types
of guns that will be in the game
so we have three distinct types of guns
in our game we have
power weapons we have tech weapons and
we have smart weapons
now power weapons are the most similar
to contemporary weapons
one thing they can do which normal
weapons cannot is ricochet bullets off
of surfaces
so you can hit somebody hiding behind
cover or hiding behind a wall
now tech weapons on the other hand use
electromagnetic power to propel
a fully metal projectile to extreme
velocities
what that allows them to do is to punch
through cover
or punch through walls to hit somebody
who's not even
aware that you're there smart weapons
use guided missile technology to
actually track targets in real time
so you can hit somebody who's dodging
running away from you
or you can hit somebody who's hiding
behind cover
so pavel cyberpunk doesn't just contain
fps elements like it's also a fully
fledged rpg
so can you tell us how you guys
approached introducing those rpg
elements into gunplay
so i can tell you one thing holly it
wasn't easy to merge those two elements
together
now uh we've spent a considerable amount
of time
merging the rpg and fpp side of our game
what the player will experience is that
v
changes from a small time mercenary to a
legend in the world of night city v
becomes
more and more proficient in using
weapons as the game progresses
so they will see that reload times
become shorter
the accuracy of your weapons grows
you will have faster aiming time you
will move faster with your weapons
everything becomes more in your control
and that gives you
more opportunities to defeat the biggest
encounters that we've designed for you
so i have prepared a few extra questions
for you pavel if you're feeling up to it
of course okay well the first is going
to be how do you
find more weapons in night city like
where will players be looking for them
so i expect the players to look
everywhere for
new and exciting weapons you can of
course buy weapons at vendor shops
and they will house an entire catalogue
of weaponry that you can get
however the best weapons that you can
find will be
taken from enemies or loot caches that
we have
everywhere in night city the weapons
rarities range from
common to uncommon up to rare and then
legendary
and as they go in rarity they actually
climb in power
however legendary weapons are very
specific
in such a way that they possess unique
abilities that you will find on no other
weapons in the game
the players will actually need to make
some tough
choices to find some legendary weapons
because maybe they need to
choose whether to kill a person who
holds the legendary weapons that they
want
or to spare them because they like them
as a character
so next question let's talk about weapon
modifications
what mods can people give to their
weapons in night city
so we have two types of modifications in
the game one of them would be
modifications that we call attachments
so these would be scopes and silencers
and you can see them
actually being attached to your weapon
as you're playing the game they give you
statistics advantage and they give you
more opportunities in gameplay
the other part of modes would be
software modes
now these are basically small chips that
you install in the
in your weapon and they actually change
the statistics of the gun
they can give you damage they can give
you accuracy or they can give you
more fire rate some of those mods
actually change the
gun play on a more fundamental level so
they can give you non-lethal rounds
biochemical rounds to tear through that
armor
even faster so i suppose for my final
question uh why don't you tell us about
your favorite weapon then
which is your favorite weapon so far in
night city
oh there are so many weapons that it's
hard to choose just
one but i can mention some manufacturers
with their weapons that i absolutely
adore
the first manufacturer would be tsunami
defense systems
who produces the sniper rifle nekomata
that's a tech sniper rifle that means
that it can pierce through walls
so you can actually hit somebody who's
hiding behind cover
or who doesn't even know you're there of
course i also like a close quarters
approach
and what that needs is a shotgun one of
the shotguns that we have in the game is
budget arms carnage
now that thing is cast from pure steel
and it weighs a ton
however you can cut a person clean in
half with it
another shotgun that i absolutely love
it's for a more refined approach i would
say
is a smart shotgun jour that thing has
eight barrels
and that means it can track eight
targets independently
now killing an entire room was never
simpler
uh pavel thank you so much for joining
me thank you for having me
i'm actually pretty interested to see
what kind of weapons people discover
when they
play cyberpunk for themselves before we
end
episode 2 this is a reminder that those
who wish to